thank you president sofa gates a
word that everyone knows and that
unfortunately has been on the front pages
of the European media
for more than 10 days and yet it
has not deserved to have its own debate in
this parliament it is a
missed opportunity I still do not understand why  that the
leaders of other political groups, with the
exception of my fellow naughty hand,
have not wanted to have a frank debate
on this issue and have preferred to
mix it with the conclusions of the
council that have little to do with it but in
any case I have to tell you that
I am very disappointed about  all because of the
embarrassing image of the European Union
that has been engraved on us in that
fateful encounter in the face because there
in that scene on the sofa something has been evidenced
that we women know very well
but that often goes unnoticed that
costs us a lot  occupy positions of
responsibility that cost us a lot
and a lot to break glass ceilings I know
michelle sir q  It was not his intention
that perhaps he did not realize the
consequences that this so-called
protocol failure had in this aspect,
but that is the problem precisely,
that is the problem that they do not realize,
that is what must be changed in
our  society and that is the change we
need to show also
in gestures, statements are not enough,
although I already told you a few weeks ago that
of course I accept your apologies because
if I, as a European woman, felt
offended, this matter has different
perspectives and today I would like to  talk about
this specific issue and why
each issue also deserves an in-
depth debate of course we have to
talk about turkey and we will have to
address very sensitive issues, among
others the decision of the ankara government
to withdraw its country from the
istanbul agreement and  I will deal with all these issues in
the plenary session in May when
Turkey is voted on, which this Parliament has already
approved in committee, but  Today I want to
ask you for a collective effort and to put
your egos aside, we need a
collective effort so that this grotesque image
of the gates sofa does not happen again and
also to demonstrate
the European Union's commitment to gender equality,
Mrs. von der Leyen, Mr.
Michelle, I was waiting.  that they
agree to make a proposal on how to
avoid this type of situation in the
future in any case let me
tell you that the treaties already provide a
solution for the
institutional complexity of the European Union and it is
the figure of the high representative in all
In this case, the diplomatic incident should not
serve as an excuse to undo the path we have
trodden, it is necessary to reinforce our
foreign and security policy because
if not, the union will be condemned to a
growing irrelevance and we do not
deserve this, that is why I ask you to make a
small effort to better coordinate  the
protocol for future occasions and
now to amend that
disastrous image I ask the  mr michelle
as
you have said and in this plenary session a
real commitment
to gender equality policies we are waiting
for the board once and for all to
unblock the directive for women
on boards of directors the
women on board that has been going on for years  blocked
in the council and we are also
awaiting the ratification by the
council of the istanbul convention that
has not yet been developed we believe
it is necessary and we believe that this is
the moment to have that feminist agenda
that europe needs and sir, to face
it well we are also waiting  of the
commission, as you have rightly said, other
types of legislative initiatives, a
European directive against gender-based violence,
which is the greatest scourge that
Europe is suffering at the moment, I know that
some of these some in this
chamber may not seem like these minor issues
They are, I assure you, and proof of this is
the repercussion that his speech has had in the
media
inaugural as president of this chamber
in 1979
simon veil paid tribute to another
european wins louis veis for her commitment
to the emancipation of women
more than 40 years have passed since that
speech but there has only been one other female
president of this european parliament-
nicole fontaine es  Saying two women in
more than 40 years, Mrs. von der Layen
is a pioneer at the head of the commission and
no woman has yet chaired the
council. The reality, ladies and gentlemen, is that in
Europe we are still at the beginning
of equality. Many perhaps do not realize it,
but  We are just
taking the first steps and we are not going
to stop, I will finish if they move our chairs,
we
will move our consciences, thank you very much